romrod mit globetrotter damm spezialist
für niedrigere trat mit globetrotter
punkt ca
[Musik]
mein vater harry und ich machen uns auf
in die berge auf 2500 metern über meer
wollen wir eine familie der nach dem
inhalt besuchen
in der letzten folge starteten während
südchina von kommen aus und reiste nach
bali heute ist unser ziel das dorf sau
sau leben noch um die tausend angehörige
danach ski minderheit die jungen wandern
in die stadt ab weil sie hier keine
arbeit finden
guten tag guten tag ich heiße barbara
wie heißen sie
mich rührt die herzlichkeit und
gastfreundschaft der menschen hier als
gast bekommt man sofort etwas zu essen
auch li shuang macht sich sogleich daran
für uns als frühstück zuzubereiten
die 67 jährige bereitet der teig für ba
zu
das sind grafen auswalzen mehl und öl
die mit honig oder chili gegessen werden
ihre manchego heißt den ofen ein
wie schlugen trägt noch immer die
traditionellen land wald oder nach china
charakteristisch ist dabei steckte
rucksack die mütze stammt noch aus der
zeit vor mao zedong
sie trägt sie immer noch
tochter mini ist zu besuch sie wohnt mit
ihrem mann in der stadt fast jedes
wochenende zieht es sie nach hause wir
nennen sie baba ist das so ähnlich wie
brot das ist unser brot
jetzt leben wir in einer wohnung in der
stadt
wir haben zwar viele nachbarn aber wir
können dagegen bin ich aufgewachsen ich
kenne alle was kindern stammten alle
türen offen
wir sprachen miteinander und alle
wandelt
jeden morgen macht sie hier wie es
mutter auf den weg um reise zusammen für
das feuer wie die meisten naschi lebt
auch sie von der landwirtschaft groß
quinlan begleitet sie der zehnjährige
hat ferien seine eltern arbeiten in der
stadt
[Musik]
die juden hat ihr ganzes leben hier
verbracht es war geprägt von harter
arbeit und verzicht ich konnte nur vier
jahre die primarschule besuchen das
einzige mädchen der familie war musste
ich viel mithelfen nach der schule muss
sich preisig sei die tiere versorgen
und als meine mutter starb konnte ich
nicht mehr zur schule wenig blöd zu
hause und halfmann vater auf dem buch
für die ausbildung ihrer brüder musste
sie zurück stehen im ländlichen china
wird in knabl investiert denn die sollen
einmal die eltern ernähren von töchter
wird erwartet dass sie heiraten und zum
ehemann ziehen hat geheiratet und ist in
die stadt eingezogen
seitdem ist es ruhiger geworden hier
aber lily überzeugte die mutter ihr haus
für fremde zu öffnen und ein bed and
breakfast zu betreiben eine kleine
revolution
am anfang glaubte ich nicht so richtig
an die idee eines betten brett frist wir
dachten das haus sei nicht gut genug für
gäste aber einige meiner ausländischen
freunde wollten bei uns übernachten und
das gefühl
so fingen wir an gäste zu bewerten aber
zu beginn hatten wir alle hemmungen weil
man nicht wusste wie man sich ausländern
gegenüber verhalten sollte
dann fielen auch andere familien damit
an
jetzt wollen alle gäste haben lillis
mutter sorgt er dafür dass ihre tochter
eine gute ausbildung bekam das machte
sie unabhängig wie sie studierte und
kamen wenige der welt
heute betreibt sie ein reisebüro in der
stadt lithang für ihre öko tourismus
projekt gewann sie 20 familien im dorf
im jahr kommen um die 150 gäste zumeist
als europa oder nordamerika sie spielen
jeden nachmittag mal die nach pflege
ihrer traditionen so treffen sich die
frauen dreimal pro woche auf dem
dorfplatz dieses lied erzählt davon wie
sie fremden von weit her kommen
willkommen heißen
aber dieses brauchtum geht verloren lily
kennt die meisten kämpfe nicht mehr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
willi erzählt mir dass heute eine
riesige schulen immerhin auch nach
gesprochen werde
nicht nur herr chinesisch wie früher die
intakte natur zieht immer mehr
chinesische touristen an
in bussen reisen sie an und
fotografieren die idylle übernachten
allerdings wollen sie in luxushotels in
der stadt auch ich will die gelegenheit
für einen ausritt nutzen
levy trat ihr viel kritik musste auf
seine boni ist aber das stört also
kräftig wie heißt du ich heiße gaulin
[Musik]
nirgendwo wäre ich jetzt lieber als auf
diesem pferderücken lily und den
menschen hier wünsche ich dass sich der
sanfte tourismus durchsetzt und die
kultur und natur erhalten bleibt
[Musik]
für oldtimer rollt hat uns wieder
unsere reise führt weiter von monschau
nachbau von mountain und london bis zur
kreisstadt
juli dann erreichen wir burma das
heutige myanmar
in den songs verbergen fahren wir durch
eine entrückte landschaft
dieses monument wurde zerstört und neu
aufgebaut
die anordnung der soldaten erinnert an
die weltberühmten terrakotta soldaten in
china
es ist ein denkmal für die kurven kann
kämpfer an jene opfer des chinesischen
bürgerkriegs deren andenken aus dem
kollektiven gedächtnis gelöscht worden
ist auf anweisung mao zedongs
[Musik]
schuljahr ein ehemaliger soldat bietet
mir an mich nach long link zu fahren
auf seinem motorrad ein hauch von burma
gold fielen
[Musik]
in langlingen besuche ich eine
gedenkstätte die die chinesen an eines
der schwersten kriegsverbrechen der
japaner erinnert kaum jemand kennt
diesen ort als wichtigster der kapitel
uhr die japanische sind die sogenannte
trust frauen das ins roxy wofür die
japanische armee in zweiter geworden
sind als prosituierte hotelschiffe und
er vor seiner route witz modellen sich
stars und da ich habe mir das museum
eingerichtet
das modell war offizieren vorbehalten
am empfang informierten holzschilder
welche frauen zu diensten standen sie
tragen namen wie sommer warm glocke oder
leinenkleid auf einer tafel benimmregeln
für die männer wie nicht länger als 30
minuten bei einer frau bleiben oder
keine schlägereien alle fangen
[Musik]
dieses haus diente als sogenanntes
trainingszentrum für waltrop oer delle
investieren
allein china zwangen die japaner während
des kriegs um die 200.000 frauen zur
prostitution
[Musik]
die frauen waren zumeist sehr jung sie
wurden von ihren familien getrennt und
verschleppt im bordell mussten sie bis
zu 50 männer am tag empfangen
[Musik]
die bezeichnung trost frauen war
beschönigend diese frauen waren rechtlos
wurden vergewaltigt gefoltert und bei
ungehorsam getötet
[Musik]
bei ihrem abzug habe die japanischen
truppen die meisten trost frauen
ermordet
niemand sollte von ihren gräueltaten
berichten können hat die polnische
regierung allgemein awards kunde um sich
für die opfer zu entschuldigen
die vorräte entschädigungszahlungen
trost frau aber sind bisher gezahlt
wurde
der bürgermeister von osaka hat sogar
der einsatz von 6,42 war krieg
rechtfertigen
china hat auf dass sie empört reagiert
und täglich japans zukunft hänge davon
ab wie es mit der vergangenheit umgehen
langsam finde ich zurück in die
gegenwart
wir sind noch immer in lünern die
provinz ist bekannt für die intakte
natur und die artenvielfalt immer mehr
menschen engagieren sich darum für
projekte wie lukrativ und nachhaltig
sind
[Musik]
wir sind im orchideen paradies von
niveau wie mal auf in ihrem garten ging
finden sich 120 verschiedene arten eine
mannschaft besonders
[Musik]
diese hier heißt wandert das bedeutet
idee der 1000 generationen für ein
langes leben
wie sehr mutterpflanzen holten wir aus
der natur durch die abholzung des
regenwaldes waren sie bedroht wir
retteten sie so konnten sie überleben
forscht in ihrem freiluft dieses öl
riecht nach weißem pfeffer holz und
eines tages entdeckt vielleicht ein paar
für mühe diesen duft und kreiert daraus
ein neues papa das ist ein sehr
sinnvolles produkt wie viele unserer
biodiversitäts produkte mit dem geld
können wir noch mehr speed is entdecken
und so den regenwald schützen
aufgebaut hat das zentrum ihrem mann
josef margraf
der renommierte deutsche botaniker war
ihre große liebe vor fünf jahren ist er
verstorben
das ist ganz und gar josefs welt er
hatte ein sehr fundiertes wissen ich
glaube in jeder flasche die er hier
zurückließ steckt eine botschaft und ich
versuche sie zu verstehen
hier ist er noch überall präsent diese
gold gehen tragen den namen zu recht wie
markgraf beliefert damit den
französischen kosmetikhersteller gerne
der die blüten zu einer gesichtscreme
verarbeitet eine der teuersten der welt
so finanziert die 45 jährige ihre
projekte
zum beispiel ihrem werk auch dort will
die margraf artenvielfalt und
biodiversität fördern
julian ist baumeister und
wirtschaftsberater als freund der
familie beredter sie bei ihrem neuesten
projekt der weg in die bu leinberger ist
beschwerlich der gestrige regen hat die
straßen beinahe unpassierbar gemacht
aber genau wegen dieser abgeschiedenheit
ist die gegend eher beschaulich und
ursprünglich geblieben
[Musik]
bis vor einigen jahren war der regen hat
hier beinahe abgeholzt gummi plantagen
und kurzfristiges gewinnstreben
verdrängten ihm heute ist vieles wieder
aufgeforstet in ihrem tee bald zeigt uns
lima graf uralte bäume aus den blättern
wird der weltbekannte partie gewonnen
diese alten bäume sind wird erwachsen
fahren nach ideen und andere bemühten
das bilde zusammen ein ganzheitliches
ökosystem die größe die mikro
biodiversität und gesünder der baum
kommt hier zur ruhe
so soll es auch anderen gehen wie
margraf plant ihren rückzugsort für
gestresste manager der tauber ist da
berät wirtschaftsmagnaten bei der
auswahl ihrer top kader und er
analysiert die landschaft mittels feng
shui kriterien
schau dir diese berge an
sie bilden zusammen das panorama sind
eins mit dem kosmos ein sehr wertvoller
ort wie margraf ist die einschätzung des
trauma ist das wichtig wenn du hier
bungalows errichtet darfst du nicht mehr
als drei bis fünf gäste pro gebäude
einnahmen die über fünf gäste auch wenn
sie statt was ihr den cheat shipping
ankündigt er sagt dass präsident schiene
kommen wird
von links zieht es mich weiter ich will
bis ganz hinauf zur grenze sie wollen
dunkle schokolade erreichen
ja genau die mag ich wie viel kostet 33
hören
[Musik]
guten tag fahren sie nach holly wieviel
30 jahren wie von franken jetzt englisch
ein wenig ein wenig ein wenig reicht
doch
meine mitfahrer sind junge menschen aus
burma die verständigung ist schwierig
bis unmöglich
sprichst du chinesisch ein wenig sie
arbeiten als taglöhner in china und sind
auf dem weg in ihre heimat
es ist ein thema das die alle zwei bis
drei tage
dann kommen wir im juli an
wir sind jetzt in der grenzstadt zu
myanmar dem ehemaligen burma
juli ist ein pulsierender ort und einer
der wichtigsten grenzübergänge chinas
der handel mit dem kleinen nachbarn
myanmar hat trulli reich gemacht
an ihrem traditionellen rock dem
launching erkennt man die vielen
burmesen hier an der grenze staue sich
unzählige laster alle sind schwer
beladen
vor allem elektronische geräte aber auch
plastik waren sind in burma gefragt wenn
die chinesischen waren sind viel
günstiger dieser grenzort ist so wichtig
weil der zugang zum meer und zugang zu
rohstoffen garantiert dieser lastwagen
bringt beton in sein heimatland
transportieren sie immer besser nein und
portieren das was gerade kommt was zb
motorräder fahrräder kleiderschränke und
war es transportieren sie aus burma
hierher wasser will wir transportieren
lassen melone erreichten release gründet
vor allem auf dem handel mit
burmesischer jahre davon leben hier
60.000 menschen meine chinesische
mitarbeiterin sie fahren und ich habe
eine verabredung mit dem präsidenten der
iaa de händlervereinigung mit lausanne
gehen wir in eine der drei riesigen
hampels hallen hier arbeiten um die 1000
verkäufer ein lukratives geschäft denn
rooney ist eine freihandelszone
hier gelten andere regeln als im übrigen
china ja der hat in china eine ganz
besondere bedeutung
sie steht für glück zufriedenheit freude
und reichtum
hauptsächlich anhänger
dieser dicke buddha steht für reichtum
oder nein
er hat ein breites lachen und an den
großen bauch er steht für glück
sein großer bauch steht für große
toleranz mit kohl reichte um sich in
china doch dasselbe denke ich mir klar
führt mich zu einem händler der ruhe
ihre steine verkauft er will mir die
unterschiedliche qualität zeigen
mit hilfe von wasser und licht wird die
güte des steins untersucht
foto
dieser stein ist nicht gut sagte sie ich
will post an ihren 2500 jahren 380
franken
aber man kann noch verhandelt es gibt
bessere steiner die aber zigtausende und
der dann ist er besser
diese zwei scheine sind sehr
unterschiedlich sie stammen nicht vom
gleichen ort wie viel kostet diese stein
zwei jahren 1600 franken
man kann alleine verhandeln ein arbeiter
in einer kabine verdient gerade mal zwei
franken am tag
wir besuchen eines der exklusivsten
juweliergeschäfte am ort das wan lee qi
das geschäft gibt es seit 20 jahren und
es floriert die klientel besteht vor
allem aus reichen chinesen chen qi ist
der geschäftsführer
das sind unsere wertvollsten ringe aus
jahren ihre farben sind sehr hell und
transparent
schauen sie mal dieses stück es ist als
wäre der körper aus wasser und die
struktur lebendig umgerechnet 390
tausend franken
dann zeigt dieses collier vereins den
europäischen stil mit chinesischer jahre
und was ist hier der preis 8 millionen
rimini 1,2 millionen franken verkauft
sich so etwas
er kann sich das leisten in der regel
können sich nur erfolgreiche chinesische
unternehmer solche stücke leisten
normalsterbliche können das nicht
bezahlen nimmt der hand ihn ideale noch
zu wenn man kann das jahr der geschäft
auch als investitionsmöglichkeit
betrachten in china ist der
immobilienmarkt in den letzten jahren
rapide gewachsen
viele sind so zu geld gekommen er gilt
heute als sichere anlage und zusätzlich
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ihr wert
steigt hoch jadestadt immobilien sagt er
wolle seine stücke an der schweizer
uhren- und schmuckmesse zeigen gerne
würde er enger mit der schweiz
zusammenarbeiten
ich glaube eben auf und schon wartet der
nächste termin penguin winkt uns zum
abschied zu an seinem handgelenk eine
teure schweizer uhr von limitierter
stückzahl
in der länge juweliergeschäfts die
andere realität viele burmesen versuchen
der bitteren armut in ihrem land zu
entfliehen
hinter diesem grenzzaun haben sie ihre
zelte aufgeschlagen
ganze familien leben hier
durch ein noch schlüpfen sie zum reichen
nachbarn china
dort versuchen sie sich mit betteln oder
schmucken durchzuschlagen
[Musik]
zurück in die luxuswelt der jahre liu
hong ist einer der berühmtesten jahre
schnitzer chinas er verkauft seine
skulpturen zu höchstpreisen für diese
kunst paare man viel erfahrung sagt liu
jeder stein habe seinen geheimcode denn
keiner so entschlüsseln können wie er
new dawn arbeitet am besten nachts das
sei auch schon früher so gewesen als er
noch musiker war erzählte er ja das
schnitzen ist sehr schwer
zuerst muss du den stein verstehen jeder
stein hat seine besondere eigenschaft er
sah musst du herausfinden wie du mit ihm
umgehen muss leo schnitzt seine figuren
gerne mal aus vorlagen von der agentin
mythen und aus der geschichte
[Musik]
über geld will er nicht sprechen aber es
ist klar dass er mit seiner kunst zu den
spitzenverdienern und gehört
[Musik]
mit dem höheren lebensstandard
heutzutage gibt es auch immer mehr
kunstinteressierte größer die nachfrage
so höher der preis
ich überlasse lido der jade und der
nacht
auch in rooney kann man auf dem
nachtmarkt bis spät abends essen wie
überall in china von maden und krebsen
lasse ich die finger
obwohl ich sehr experimentierfreudig bin
gekochte schildkröten würde ich aus
prinzip nie essen
[Musik]
gleich neben dem markt entdecken wir
diese monströsen skulpturen aus holz
dafür werden wir mal ganze wälder
gerodet
oft wird das holz geschmuggelt und hier
verarbeitet der heißhunger chinas macht
auch vor menschen nicht haut diese
frauen simple singen um der armut in
ihrer heimat zu entgehen verkaufe die in
china ihre körper nicht ohne grund wird
diese gegend wilder westen genannt
unsere recherchen zum jahr der handel
für adobes zu diesem hinterhof haus hier
treffen wir ja alle händler aus burma
die gehirn so karen minderheit auf deren
gebiet die meisten jahre minen liegen
von den riesen gewinnen profitierten nur
die regierungen chinas und burmas sagen
sie dann schildern sie uns die
unmenschlichen arbeitsbedingungen in den
jahr gewesen die heroinabhängigkeit der
arbeiter und die riskanten wege das jahr
des schmucks normalerweise bringen wir
die steine mit dem auto marina es gibt
zahlreiche checkpoints an jede müssen
wir bezahlen
immer wenn die kämpfe zwischen unserer
katzen armee und der regierung wieder
ausbrechen benutzen wir die trampelpfade
durch den dschungel
die steine werden von menschen elefanten
oder pferden transportiert diese männer
riskieren für wenig geld zwischen die
fronten der regierungstruppen und der
cutscene armee zu geraten und erschossen
zu werden
das schicksal der burmesischen quatschen
beschäftigt mich weiter ein
verbindungsmann es bereit uns zu einem
coaching camp zu führen
seit jahrzehnten wird diese minderheit
von der burmesischen regierung verfolgt
und genauso lange kämpft sie für ihre
unabhängigkeit
unterwegs kreuzen immer wieder schwer
beladene laster mit teakholz unseren weg
er kommt aus birma
[Musik]
dann fahren wir über eine brücke
nach und nach realisieren ich dass wir
in myanmar sind unser verbindungsmann
hat uns über die grüne grenze gebracht
wir erfahren dass die han front zwischen
aufständischen und den burmesischen
regierungssoldaten nur 15 kilometer
entfernt ist
[Musik]
schließlich erreichen wir das
flüchtlingslager der quatschen
diese menschen sind die leidtragenden
eines jahrzehnte lange schwelenden
konflikt
das camp wurde vor drei jahren errichtet
fast alle hilfsorganisationen sind
wieder weg aber immerhin gibt es eine
schule für die kinder
wir schauen uns im lager mit 3000
coaching angehörigen um die meistens im
podesten und christen
sie leben in ähnlichen gemeinschaften
wie früher
nach den angestammten dörfern unterteilt
das gäbe ein stück vertrautheit zurück
erklärt man uns das leben hier ist
entbehrungsreich es fehlt an allem die
ernährung ist schlecht sauberes wasser
knapp und die hygiene miserabel
viele frauen haben auf ihrer flucht
schreckliches erlebt und wurden von
burmesischen soldaten vergewaltigt viele
von ihnen sind traumatisiert
zu den vertriebenen gehört auch nach
kongo
sie ist anfang 40 und mutter von vier
kindern
es war ende november 2011
dort forscht er kam zu uns und wie es
uns an zuvor zu fliehen weil das
burmesische militär immer mehr gebiete
erobern und anfiel und anzugreifen
wir verließen das dorf sofort alles was
wir dabei hatten war ein wenig reis vier
tage und nächte haben wir im wald
verbracht
später kamen wir hier ins
flüchtlingscamp die zukunft ihrer kinder
aus die größte hoffnung für die kinder
ist eine gute bildung
das ist auch der grund weshalb wir hier
bleiben die kinder können hier zur
schule gehen
das wäre in unserem dorf unmöglich dort
hat das burmesische militär alles
besetzt
viele kinder kennen kein anderes leben
aus dass im camp hier ist hier zu hause
ihre lebensfreude und ihr lachen geben
auch den müttern ein stück zuversicht
und hoffnung zurück
wir verlassen das camp und kehren zurück
zurollt bulle roth wir sind nun also in
myanmar hier der grenzregion ist der
einfluss chinas überall spürbar
der ausbau und der unterhalt der straße
beispielsweise wird von china finanziert
um den warenfluss von west nach ost zu
beschleunigen
wir sind auf einer der größten handels-
und schmuggelrouten asiens dieser fahrer
hat einen zwischenhalt eingelegt und die
bremsen zu kühlen man übersetzer leon
die ich bitten ihn um eine
mitfahrgelegenheit nach sido möchte per
lastwagen dort können sie uns mitnehmen
ich kann euch mitnehmen ich hoffe dass
wir keine schwierigkeiten haben
unterwegs
der lastwagenfahrer spielt die kämpfe
zwischen bewaffneten rebellen und der
regierungsarmee an
immer wieder flammen sie auch während
wir hier unterwegs sind
[Musik]
der fahrer genehmigt sich eine beten los
die ihn auf putzt man ins auto fährt 18
stunden schichten
er arbeitet seit 20 jahren als
lastwagenchauffeur zumeist transportiere
heraus erzählt er
wohin ich schaue sehe ich riesiger
gerodete flächen als das oft illegal
nach china verkauft wurde
mami zu tun beteuert er transportiere
nur legale waren ich transportiere
nichts illegales
denn ich will noch lange weiter arbeiten
ich gehöre nicht zu denen die schmuggeln
und in kurzer zeit sehr viel geld
verdienen wollen
während der fahrt muss sich an die
gewaltigen umwälzungen in myanmar in den
letzten jahren denken
auf meine frage hin ob sich für ihn seit
dem ende der militärdiktatur viel
verändert habe zögert er
seit 2012 hat sich für mich nicht viel
verändert der grenzverkehr ist einfacher
geworden aber das wichtigste für mich
ist dass sich die familie ernähren kann
das ist meine hauptsorge
[Musik]
tag für tag herrscht hier in der region
leder grenzverkehr von china nach
mandala
[Musik]
im zib riecht der morgen an
hier leben angehörige haben in der haid
um die ihren letzten prinzen rankt sich
eine der tragischsten liebesgeschichten
burmas darüber will ich mehr erfahren in
der nächsten folge
dann lerne ich auch diese familie kennen
sie reißen so diplom war ihrer tochter
nach mandalay ein großer tag für alle
firma ist auf dem weg zur demokratie
davon ist münchen keller überzeugt aber
es brauche viel zeit und blattgold für
bruder mit diesem hauchdünnen goldfolie
verbessern gläubige ihr karma
[Musik]
rot grün rot mit globetrotter uns im
fernseher ist die wahl siebte bis achte
november im kursaal bern fernsehfestival
punkt ch